مرارا وتكرارا، وألمانيا تسجن كل من يضع رمز
أحد الحروف بسبب موسكو، والكرملين
لا يقبل إلا بعملته المحلية مقابل غازه
المصدر للدول غير الصديقة،،
مع تعافٍ للروبل الروسي مقارنة بالشهر الماضي...
(غضب فرنسي من روسيا)..
القصة بدأت مع نشر السفارة الروسية
كاريكاتيرا ساخرا، لرجل مريض
يحمل اسم أوروبا يحقنه طبيبان يمثلان
الاتحاد الأوروبي وأمريكا بالإبر،،
مرفقة برسائل مثل: كراهية الروس
و covid19,  الخارجية الفرنسية
استدعت السفير الروسي ووصفت الرسم
الكاريكاتيري بغير المقبول،
لترد المتحدثة باسم الخارجية الروسية ماريا زاخاروفا
: حين أعربت عن دهشتها من اعتراض
باريس على الكاريكاتير، لكون فرنسا نفسها
سمحت سابقا برسوم مسيئة للنبي محمد،
وسوغت الفعل حينها بأنها في إطار حرية التعبير،،
ففي عام ٢٠٠٦ أحدثت صحيفة شارلي إيبدو
الفرنسية ضجة عالمية بعد نشرها ١٢ رسما
مسيئا للنبي صلى الله عليه وآله وسلم
وفي عام ٢٠٢٠ وقعت حادثة مشابهة
بعد أن نُشرت رسوم مسيئة للنبي على واجهات
بعض المباني، متزامنة مع تصريحات للرئيس
ماكرون مدافعا عن الرسوم...
(خووف أمريكي)
الجانب الأمريكي سرعان ما يطلق التصريحات
وسرعان ما يتراجع عنها فهل أحدثت موسكو
إرباكا حقيقيا داخل الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية؟
بايدن: لقد تغير العالم ومنافسة روسيا والصين
تتطلب زيادة الاستثمار في الفضاء والأسلحة
الفرط صوتية..
وهنا بايدن يتراجع عن حديثه عن بوتين
ويقول بأنه شخصي وليس رسميا بقوله:
ماقلته عن بوتين كان تعبيرا عن إحساسي بالغضب
مما رأيته ولا تغيير في سياستنا تجاه موسكو،،
كنت أعبر عن غضبي الشخصي ولا أعتذر عما قلت..
(الطائرة المتسكعة)
هي المسيرة الحديثة التي  دخلت الحرب
ويجري تحضيرها للقتال مع الجيش الأوكراني،
بعد وصول ١٠٠ طائرة منها إلى كييف،
(سويتش بليد) مسيرة انتحارية ذات قدرات خاصة،
حجمها لا يتجاوز رغيف الخبز،
لكنها تتفوق على صاروخ جافلين الموجه،
مصممة لتدمير أهداف ثابتة ومتحركة،
تحلق لمدة ١٥ دقيقة ولمسافة ١٠كيلو مترات.
وعند تحديد الهدف تنطلق نحوه بسرعة ١٦٠ كم
وتنفجر، رغم أن وزنها لا يتجاوز ٢.٥كجم،
فهل يستفيد منها الجيش الأوكراني بتدمير
بطاريات دفاع القوات الروسية؟
تحاول تركيا حل حرب أوكرانيا سلميا برغم
أنها أحد أعضاء حلف الناتو،
فهل يعد ذلك خوفا من الدب الروسي
أم محاولة لرفع مكانة الأتراك في أوروبا؟
ويجتمع المفاوضون الأوكران والروس
للمرة الأولى منذ أسبوعين، في الوقت الذي تسعى
فيه كييف إلى وقف إطلاق النار دون التنازل
عن الأراضي أو السيادة.
أردوغان المفاوضات بين روسيا وأوكرانيا
دخلت مرحلة تحقيق نتائج حاسمة،،
لدى الطرفين مخاوف مشروعة ويمكن التوصل
إلى حل خلال هذه المفاوضات يضمن مصالحهما معا".
ندعو إلى وقف فوري لإطلاق النار،
وقال أردوغان إن وقف المأساة "متروك لكلا الجانبين".،
واستمرار الصراع لا يخدم أي طرف"، حسب تعبيره.
(الأحداث والتطورات)
ألمانيا تجرّم حمل أو نشر الحرف Z بالأبيض،
بسبب العملية العسكرية الروسية في أوكرانيا،
حيث يستخدمه الجيش الروسي كشارة لقواته
في أوكرانيا، وعقوبة كل من يرفع الرمز Z
خلال تظاهرة أو طلاء سيارات أو أبنية،
السجن ٣ سنوات أو عقوبة مالية..
وكانت موسكو قد قالت أن الحرف Z يعني
من أجل النصر، بينما يستخدم الجيش الروسي
هذه الرموز لتمييز معداته عن معدات الأوكرانيين...
تراجع سعر صرف الدولار إلى ما دون ٩٠
روبلا روسيا للمرة الأولى منذ بداية الحرب
القوات الأوكرانية تصد ٧ هجومات
روسية في دونيتسك ولوغانسك،، وموسكو
تستمر بقصف خاركيف
روسيا تصف حلف الناتو بأنه آلة موجهة
وتؤكد أنها لن تزود أوروبا بالغاز مجانا،
وقال المتحدث باسم «الكرملين» الروسي،
دميتري بيسكوف، إن «موسكو» لا تنوي
التفكير في إرسال قواتها إلى أي دولة من الأعضاء
في حلف شمال الأطلسي «الناتو» إلا في خطوة جوابية،
أو إذا اضطروها لذلك،
بيسكوف: مهما كانت حصيلة العمليات العسكرية
الجارية في أوكرانيا فإن ذلك لا يبرر
استخدام الأسلحة النووية، ولن يتم استخدام هذه الأسلاحة
إلا في حال تهديد وجودي لروسيا..
الكرملين: روسيا ستبحث آلية لتلقي مدفوعات
صادراتها من الغاز بالروبل الروسي
بيسكوف يحشر أوروبا في الزاوية بقوله
إن موسكو لن تورد النفط مجانا لأوروبا
ولن تنخرط في أعمال خيرية لأوروبا
أرسلت وزارة الدفاع الأمريكية «البنتاجون»،
طائرات تشويش إلى ألمانيا لتعزيز قدرات
حلف شمال الأطلسي«الناتو»، وأوضحت الوزارة،
أن طائرات التشويش لن يتم استخدامها
ضد روسيا في أوكرانيا.
وأضاف «البنتاجون»، أن 240 من أفراد
البحرية الأمريكية سيرافقون طائرات التشويش
إلى ألمانيا،
دفاع بريطانيا: نتوقع نشر مجموعة فاغنر أكثر
من ألف عنصر في أوكرانيا..
الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان قديروف
في زيارة لجنوده في ماريوبول لرفع معنويات
الجيش لتحرير المدينة، ورافقت الزيارة
جلب معدات إضافية للقوات..
السلطات الأوكرانية تقدر خسائرها الاقتصادية
بنحو 565مليار دولار
بيسكوف  بلادنا تعيش في وسط عدائي،
وتشعر بأنها في خضم حرب اقتصادية
وبحاجة للتكيف مع الظروف الجديدة.
..
أردوغان تركيا هي الدولة الوحيدة تقريبا
التي بذلت جهودا صادقة  من أجل حل الأزمة
أعلن وزير الداخلية الأوكراني أن قوات بلاده
“حرّرت” إربين، إحدى ضواحي كييف.
وزيرة الخارجية البريطانية: سأضغط في اجتماع الناتو
القادم لوضع جدول زمني لفك الارتباط بالغاز
والنفط الروسيين.
بايدن عبر تويتر: الاقتصاد الروسي
كان يحتل المرتبة الـ11 عالميا قبل الغزو
وقريبا لن يكون ضمن الـ20 الأوائل.
وزارة الدفاع الروسية: تدمير مستودعات أوكرانية
ضخمة للذخائر في مقاطعة جيتومير
بصواريخ مجنحة من طراز كاليبر.
البنتاغون: الطائرات المتجهة إلى ألمانيا
متخصصة في الحرب الإلكترونية
ولن تُستخدم ضد القوات الروسية بأوكرانيا.
وزير الخارجية القطري: لا نفكر في استثمارات
جديدة في روسيا نظرا للوضع الحالي
حتى تتضح الرؤية بشأن الاستقرار.
وأضاف: لن نتردد في مساعدة الروس والأوكرانيين
للتوصل إلى أرضية مشتركة تنهي الكارثة الإنسانية.
وزير الخارجية الروسي:
سنقوم بدعم مواطنينا أينما كانوا
والدعم القانوني لممثلي الجاليات الروسية في الخارج.
زيلينسكي: سننتصر بالتأكيد والأمر مجرد مسألة
وقت لكننا نحتاج إلى الدعم العسكري من الغرب.
الكرملين: بوتين أوعز للحكومة والبنك المركزي
وغاز بروم بتغيير عملة الدفع مقابل الغاز للروبل،
للدول التي وصفها بغير الصديقة
مبعوثة أمريكا لدى الناتو:
لا يمكن أن نسمح لبوتين بمواصلة الأعمال العدائية،،
وقدمنا مساعدات فتاكة بقيمة ملياري دولار لأوكرانيا..
لافروف: الغرب شعر بالخزي لأن خطته بتحويل
أوكرانيا إلى دولة معادية لنا قد فشلت
قال المستشار الألماني أولاف شولتس،
إن تغيير النظام في روسيا ليس هدف حلف الناتو
وليس هدف جو بايدن، رغم الحرب الأوكرانية
ألمانيا تبحث شراء نظام صاروخي بعيد المدى،
خوفا من هجوم روسي..
زعيم الانفصاليين في لوغانسك يعتزم إجراء
استفتاء بشأن الانضمام إلى روسيا
صور لرفع علم (إقليم دونيتسك) على مبنى بلدية
تابعة لمدينة ماريوبول..
لدى الغرب أن يقتل شعب مسلم مسألة فيها نظر،
لكن أن يقتل شخص منهم فهي كبيرة من الكبر،
قضية أوضحتها موسكو في تصريحاتها،،
وماذا بعد هذه العنصرية أيها الغربيون؟
..
.